oh hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember and so you don't have to today
we are looking at movie feces the
leavings of a totally horrible piece of
crap and oh look at this look at this I
have found a spectacular one right here
that is puffing nasty and we're lucky we
may be able to track down what produce
this horrible piece of dung ah just as I
suspected I thought this came from a Tim
Allen cavity right over there you can
see what produced this wretched
piece-of-shit jungle the jungle
look at how sloppy the writing is look
at how confused the humor is and ask
yourself why the hell there's a - in the
title even though this is a remake and
not a sequel we must be very quiet while
we observe it but let us venture forth
and see what could possibly create such
a giant piece of anus brother look at
that oh yes we observe here the cleanest
and most pasty white of Amazon tribesman
who like to stand on the edge of
mountaintops and scream inspiringly
for the trailer
we then cut to the next best thing that
this family film surely things will get
the kids invested the stock market 300
lots of coffee futures you called it a
hunch
no Richard I called that an opportunity
Lots in this market is not an
opportunity it's a death wish knowing
that your kids are no doubt sucked in by
all this technical talk the film then
proceeds to go to a subject matter that
kids want to hear even more about
divorce proceedings I'm getting married
to Charlotte in 30 days in order to do
that I need the divorce from Patricia
you'll overnight in Caracas then fly to
come time in the next morning will you
be met today so Tim Allen's character
whose name you will never call him so
let's just keep calling him Tim Allen is
off to the Amazon to get a divorce from
his wife so he can marry another woman
weird and complicated
oh that's merely the icing on this cake
of bullshit we received this letter from
your wife today
Senora Cromwell says that she could not
come to canaima but she wants us to get
you to bleep only wait a second what are
you talking about I travel 3,000 miles
to get here G doesn't show up what's
that about after being attacked by
deadly rubber fish Tim Allen enters this
knockoff of the mission and we see his
wife Patricia notice how their
hairstyles indicate that they met at a
Marc summers jew-fro convention very
popular in the 90s we weren't even
married a year and you walked out on me
now you want a divorce and you think I'm
gonna hit you up for money we both want
a divorce and aren't you I don't want
any money
great so we observe that she left
because he didn't listen to her much
when they were married I guess he also
didn't listen to the bar where she was
apparently leaving nor the incredibly
fourth plot point that he has a son I
know it every time but I was he 797 Oh
cortico am i greedy I'm feel pretty
greedy I'm surviving wait here so 97 and
a half the boys sitting next to the fire
over there is your son I must have
started a thousand letters to tell you
but every one of them started with I
know you never wanted children this is
nuts
this is nuts is unbelievable that was
good you don't either said to me this is
unforgivable I'm asking you to forgive
me but he didn't do anything so don't
blame him so as you can quickly observe
in this film these are all in fact
horrible people she has a son for 13
years and never tells him he's too
invested in his
stocks and bonds and there's a Tarzan
wedlock because of it Mimi siku I uh
maybe siku I'm Michael Cromwell the
boy's name is Mimi siku and yes I've
heard mainly your names out of
paranormal activity as well paliku tells
me that that I'm I'm your father that's
a nice pot you have oh and as you can
clearly see poor Tim Allen can't even
tell the difference between a pot and a
pan right he got that wrong Denny
there's some controversy about that
don't leave any comments of ours
not doing another fuck video so he
thinks that his son can't understand him
but the child reveals the next day that
he can thus adding to the contingency of
Liars that makes up this family I've got
to go back to my village I'm a trader
that's what I do it listen your village
yes women who hold fire up skies but
I've never I've never had her described
quite like that this of course raises
the question how anyone even a lone
tribesman can confuse raising a hand as
holding something up the skies but would
answering a question in class be
concert' the skies cavity check with a
high five make these to the skies
proctologists even me me we see is
double-fisting the sky up the anus
earlier so we come to the conclusion
that there's deduction and then there's
just morons and the morons who encourage
the morons when I'm a man will you take
me to Statue of Liberty
sure well yeah we then see Mimi's Pen
spider motika who Allen does not treat
very well I will
about we all this is another curious
moment if the spider is in fact his pet
why does he look so playful when Allen
plunges a rock after it almost smashing
it to smithereens you know say someone
threw a rock at your cat would you laugh
it off as a comedic moment let's find
out oh my god Rico's crackers no no son
of a bitch you can movie franchise
baboon is your pinara hey baboon well at
first they wanted to go with man who
must be smarter than he looks if we get
to pick our own names I'd like to pick
this man who's extremely well-endowed
this moment brought to you by Disney it
turns out Mimi goes through a ceremony
that officially makes him a man so he
expects Ellen to hold up his end of the
bargain and take him to New York maybe
see a view back to the exchange floor
I'm getting married I cannot take you
tomorrow here if you make a promise you
keep it perhaps she means like the
promise she made that she would meet
Alan outside the plane at the airport
thus not putting him in this mess to
begin with hypocritical bitch this is
the most important day in your son's
life I know you're gonna humiliate him
in front of the whole tribe by not
keeping the first promise you ever made
to him the son you only told him about
two days ago again hypocritical biatch
me happy to be with you a baboon
as you probably deduced he of course
decides to take him with and not bring
the mother for some reason you know the
drill bitch of the hypocritical type as
we see Alan meets up with his assistant
why didn't you sell he did not confirm
what's coffee doing now it's under 90
cents in gone limit down for 15 years
Michael you say sells I sit confirm so
confirm
so confirm you confirm and I sell you
didn't confirm so I didn't sell once
again children get to hear that riveting
stock market talk no wonder they put
this as a double feature with Wall
Street Oliver Stone would be so proud by
tomorrow morning it could be 85 or lower
we just waited out something will happen
the market will turn around his boss
isn't half
that the stocks they didn't sell are now
doing poorly and me me miss interprets
this as said spider lose to commit
murder look up that's it an alien circle
with Mickey Rourke's picture and a look
at it Mikey could kill chief I said I
was gonna go fight the chief that kill a
chief around here only postal employees
kill chief you may also catch on to Tim
Allen's only role in this movie and
that's to recite all the lines that
didn't make it into unfunny episodes of
home improvement fu PE you put the seat
back down females and tribes start war
over this magic no magical baby
understands English yellow number five
and zinc oxide added a sunblock - wait
wait I tell a lie many of those jokes
were from the Geico caveman show yeah
you totally forgot that existed didn't
you
so Allen goes to see his fiancee who was
a fashion designer and Mimi immediately
falls in love with Martin Schwartz
daughter played by leelee sobieski angel
on table and now we come to the public
service announcement part of our show
this is from all you aspiring writers
out there for everybody out there who's
looking to get something published in
Hollywood don't ever use the word angel
in your screenplay ever remember how
well it worked in the first spider-man
movie you grabbed me and said Aunt May
and Mehdi is that an angel that was
heinous how about when that little Star
Wars pimple said it are you an angel
any movie even starring an angel seems
to be geared for pigshit failure so
please do yourself a favor and act like
you never heard of them unless you're
doing a parody of It's a Wonderful Life
that's okay after Mimi pulls us done
walking on the ledge of a building
allen's fiancee is concerned that she
doesn't have what it takes to look after
him I don't think so
why he's just visiting I want to show
him a good time after that he goes back
home and we can go back to being exactly
the way we were entirely wrapped up in
ourselves just like real New Yorkers
but Mimi finds it still rather difficult
to fit in today
Wow
after you calm down your children from
seeing a pigeon getting stabbed with a
neck you yourself might be wondering is
this funny or horrifying even that
woman's scream seems hostile a brutal
you laugh but then you ask am I going to
hell for laughing at that either way it
deserves the Disney logo alan has to go
to work so he puts Mimi in the hands of
his fiancee oh wait I can't watch him
you need to babysit him he'll be fine
yes you don't need to babysit a kid who
walks around on the ledge of building
sets loose killer spiders and nearly
decapitates innocent birds he'll be a
welcomed addition to the State
Penitentiary
oh and we can add sex offender to that
lineup too nice Poochie Poochie that is
the last what you push you're gonna see
around here you little savage ah yes
this is yet another classic Disney
phrase that'll make it in the Disney
Archives
Hakuna Matata means no worries Zippity
doo-dah means what a wonderful day and
pushy bushy means dried up I can see
that on children's shirts in a
millisecond so motika is set loose again
to partake in what I think is the fifth
overyou spider joke and Mimi sets his
sights for the Statue of Liberty and
even manages to make his way there
undetected even though all these people
are looking right at him and yet they
tell no one an interesting trait of New
Yorkers but not a surprising one Allen
is called in about Mimi climbing the
Statue and he tries to explain the ways
of New York life didn't I tell you to
wait in the Bible he's got you Liberty I
said we do that tomorrow always tomorrow
you think busy for Mimi siku I want to
see Sasha Liberty I go now you might be
asking yourself wasn't he just saying me
instead of I in an earlier scene me
happy to be with you baboon
well there's a very good reason for that
oh fuck it I just want you there woman
scream again so his assistant finds
someone else who was interested in
buying the stock which it turns out is
the Russian mafia
that's just my cover let's go you fellow
Zig girl Saddam
come you took beams you might be
wondering how a movie about a boy in the
jungle got to a point in the story where
they're talking about the Russian mafia
we're gonna take a short little break
well I figure that out
okay I think I figured it out um the
loyalty of the stockholders is at risk
so they asked several people around who
have money they all have zany solutions
to the problem but what seemed
investment worthy with no backfires at
all so they entered into a deal of
business with them sneakily and smoothly
that might be a to I won't guarantee the
price not a little below 75 well would
you look at that it appears we have come
across Jumba from lilo and stitch
no I'm not even kidding that's really
him he's also codsworth and the bad guy
from Pocahontas obviously what this
movie is trying to say with this casting
decision is that Russians are a
light-hearted cartoony folk if you will
that shouldn't be taken too seriously on
any occasion I mean just look at their
leader looks like a funny guy Alan tells
the assistant to get out of the deal but
he foolishly sells the stock to them
anyway but this doesn't get in the way
of more sentimental moments like this
one
why did pellicle leave you baboon I
probably took her for granted but now
you would Charlotte yes I am many
females in your village baboon mm-hmm
why you pick only one when you pick one
to love very different by the way don't
you love how he had to think about that
for a moment
he didn't immediately turn it down like
he thought to himself yes I should get
some more hoes in my life but obviously
something snapped him out of it many
females in your village baboon mm-hmm
while you pick only one Oh No when you
pick one to love very different so Alan
convinces the mafia later that they want
to buy the stock because they don't want
to do dealings with the Russian mafia
but as soon as they do buy the stock
back it goes up making the Mafia think
they scammed them on purpose and again
do your children really have the
slightest interest in any of this why
don't we go
- showing Pocahontas for the girls and
more animal abuse for the boys playing
with the blowgun of course like a
rational parent would huh now some of
you may find the abundance of animal
cruelty in this movie slightly
disheartening but not nearly as
disheartening as me me starting his one
boy called for as you can observe he
paints her face has her speak a new
language and even gives her a new
identity oh good it's pretty her parents
must be thrilled
uh uh sort of wildfire in my yard you're
eight my yellow dwarf cichlid and now
you're putting uh moves my
twelve-year-old daughter nothing
happened
well you know what Karen you're still
going to camp an all-girls camp
my name's not Karen anymore to Kume
that's right Karen your slave name
however the Russian mafia breaks in and
holds the family hostage including
little leelee sobieski no that seems
kind of pointless we all know that she's
going to join a shady Russian business
in the future anyway no I teach you
never look at food giovanna vajayjay
look Tony interrupts we are witnessing
what many Disney does were experiencing
at that time we painfully awkward forced
slapstick climax Shh let us marvel at
how unfunny it is one gang is working
leaving the slightest game shy with the
kissters I made up notice the absence of
a smile on my face oh well I hope you
feel privileged about what you just
witnessed what's up with the Vulcan
filming so the Russian mafia are scared
away by a spider I do wish I was
exaggerating that and we see that Mimi
has to go back home Allen tries to give
back the blowgun but the son wants him
to keep it if you kill a fly you'll be a
real Benari yeah like that's gonna
happen
so it turns out one day at the stock
market that he does in fact see a fly
literally stabs his boss in the back for
it says fuck you to his fiance and heads
down to his unnatural habitat there were
some intelligent animals in this movie
right
now your Pinar a battle you killed a
totally harmless creature that we can
get no use out of
we even see Sofia Sookie's family come
with as her father is totally cool with
her diving into piranha infested waters
and getting it on with dances with
mullets
[Music]
do you see now how a film like this can
produce something like that experts
would describe this as a pretty bad
flick the family connections are
considered weak the logic makes little
sense and most of the jokes are what's
the word I'm looking for is bad however
a good chunk of animals get hurt and now
here in the jungle that's always good
for ratings I'm in this now Japan I was
down by brick and stone by stone y'all
find a way to build a wall knowing that
is more